well I've published clarify my spoonful
of sugar um the the the way that with
running with scissors the humor was like
a spoonful of sugar that makes the
medicine go down that's true just as
humorous is a life raft in terrible
terrible circumstances it can kind of
float you to the next safe spot with
running with scissors it's not that I
would sprinkle some sugar on to a bitter
peace it's that I would just not I would
leave out the bitter peace you know wolf
at the table much darker book much
darker book both books though are like
icebergs tiny tiny little chunk above
the surface of the water very small but
yeah kind of know what else is
underneath the water you know it's
pretty much going to be the same but
more and for that reason the period of
my life and running with scissors was a
lot more fun it was absolute madness and
I mean I didn't know how I was going to
turn out from that oven it was fun but
the time of my life before with my
father was not fun and in order to write
that wolf book I had to I had to go back
in my head to that time in shutesbury
Massachusetts and I had to UM I had to
be with him again and even though I'm a
lot older now and he's dead that is you
know interesting information that
matters not at all because these
memories are very they're very vivid
they're very vivid so while I was
writing that
look I was going through all the
emotions you know you would go through
during the I wouldn't want to do it
again you know i wouldnt want to do it
again it was not fun it was a not fun
and I did it I kind of had to do it for
me and then I decided to publish it
because I thought you know if I've
learned anything from this memoir things
it's that all the ways I thought I was a
freak it turns out there are other
freaks that are this you know or people
that have just experienced exactly the
same stuff so I bet there are a lot of
other guys or I thought of guys who had
the same father who went through the
same thing and even if there's only a
few of them this is gonna be useful for
them so that was the story of their with
that